All right, so let's talk about the high
level interaction between the listView
and ArrayAdapter.
And then we'll dive into
the code in the next video.
So you can think of a ListView as
being powered by the ArrayAdapter.
So without the adapter the ListView
is just an empty container.
And when I say powered by, I mean that
the ArrayAdapter holds onto the set of
data that should be shown onto screen.
So for example, it can hold on to
an array or even a list of data.
So the ArrayAdapter knows how
to translate this data, or
adapt it, into a list item view that
will be displayed in the ListView.
So let's take a look at
the details of how all this works.
So when you first associate an adapter
to a ListView the ListView will ask,
how many items that
you expect to display?
And the ArrayAdapter
knows this information.
So the ListView calls
the method on the ArrayAdapter.
And in this method
it'll pass in an input,
which is the current position in the
list that the user is currently viewing.
In this case, it passes in the position
0, but the user might be on
the 1st position, or maybe even
the 100th position in the list.
So knowing this information,
the ArrayAdapter checks
the internal source of data.
So give this case, it checks the array.
It might also check a list
if that is the source data.
And it gets the information out.
And it has instructions
to tell it how to create
a list item view that it'll
return to the ListView.
Now when the screen is full,
the ListView will stop asking for
more list items from the ArrayAdaptor.
So the list item views are only
created on demand when needed.
So when the views
are scrolled off screen,
remember that they're
added to this scrap pile.
So in this specific example,
remember that Jane and Karl,
the first two list items,
are no longer visible.
And so they'll end up in the scrap pile.
And then we can actually reuse
those views by passing the back
to the ArrayAdaptor when
we request a new list item.
So the ListView will request the list
item view for a certain position in
the list, and also pass along a view
that was previously used before.
So in this example, the ListView is
requesting for the item at position 6,
and passing in the reusable view
from before to the ArrayAdapter.
Now, the ArrayAdapter can
use the recycled view
by just placing the data inside of it.
For example, by calling the text view
setText method to change the name here.
And now it looks like a brand new list
item that we can return to the ListView
to be added to the new hierarchy and
displayed on screen.